[Musique]
ils sont venus nombreux en
avant-première découvrir l'exposition de
deux artistes réunionnais au musée léon
dierx la première collection de charles
prime s'intitule un peu de bleu dans le
paysage ce qui se passe c'est que je
reprends souvent d'être des corps qui
les décors qui existait sur ces photos
sur ces images donc les paysages anciens
qui ont beau être avoir été représentée
il ya 200 ans bouger pour autant je
remets en scène des situations
le second artiste charly lesquelin
expose une série de toiles sous le thème
traces fantômes des paysages et les
décors inspirés des contes et des
légendes de la réunion qui transporte le
visiteur dans un monde imaginaire
en fait ça nous dresser domaine le
visiteur chez les sentiers qui n'existe
pas mais dans son propre esprit qu'on
est en fin de compte c'est lui il faut
du tout si on la fait pas lui même dont
moi me fait un début de chantier
ils sont formés par lui même il faut y
trouve des animaux des failles tout
démontrer défaut d'autre chose
donc là
énigmatique dans le cadre de son projet
de mandature le département met à
disposition des artistes ces équipements
culturels pour créer et exposer leur
département doit continuer sur ce projet
de résidences d'artistes et nous pouvons
annoncer aujourd'hui retravaillé tous
ceux qui veulent participer a conçu que
nous allons le lancer le prochain appel
à projets pour les résidences d'artistes
très bien sous pour le deuxième semestre
2010 mines on vous a vu à tous à vous
préparer à répondre
cet appel à projets
[Musique]